[موسيقى]
بدايتنا اليوم عن محادثاتنا المستقبليه
ذكيه محادثات وحوارات مع الذكاء الاصطناعي
يبدو انها ستكون صريحه وجريئه وربما غاضبه
وعنصريه بالفعل راينا مؤخرا كيف اجتاح
العالم واحداث صدمه واليوم الصدمه تتكرر
مع محرك البحث بينج الذي اعتمد نفس
التكنولوجيا وتبين ان بعض ردوده تعمل قدرا
من العضوئيه العدائيه والعنصريه النصوص
التي انتهجها بينج يبدو انها تاثرت بواقع
الكراهيه على الانترنت لتصبح نسخه من
الردود البشريه كما يؤكد بعض المستخدمين
كل ذلك عكس حرجا كبيرا على مايكروسوفت
التي اعترفت بالخطا وقالت انها تعمل على
حل المشكله وهنا نتذكر ربما ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي لا يخترع شيئا بل يستعيد ابداع
الانسان ويبدو ان الانسان مبدع وعنصري في
نفس الوقت المزيد
[موسيقى]
وبالحديث عن بين الجديد فان مايكروسوفت
اطلقته بالاعتماد على تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي في سعي منها لسحب
البساط من تحت منافساتها جوجل في سوق
محركات البحث المحرك الجديد طور باستخدام
وكشف عن قبل عدد سنوات وتحديدا في 2009
يوفر محرك بينجا العديد من الميزات من
منتجات الويب والفيديو والصور وخريطه
البحث والكثير من الفلاتر المتقدمه فضلا
عن القواميس وتتبع الطيران ولعل اهم ما
يوفر المحرك هو الدردشه التوليه المعتمده
على الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي تتوقع الشركه
ان تغري الموريننيين وتحقق الكثير من
المكاسب وتسعى مايكروسوفت لاستغلال
الدردشه توليد في الاعلانات عبر الروابط
الماجوره ضمن اجابات برنامج دردشه الخاص
بها بينك تشات بوت
[موسيقى]
ينضم الى سنجداوي اكاديميه مستشار في
اداره العمل الرقميه اهلا بكم في صباح
العربيه اعتماد محرك بينك على التقنيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي الى اي مدى سيهدد ويسحب
البساط من جوجل في سوق محركات البحث صباح
الخير طبعا بدايه حاليا
الارقام هي تتحدث ان السيطره وما زالت
السيطره الكبرى لشركه جوجل بينج يعني لا
يحقق اكثر من 300 من
عمليات او احصائيات الابحاث على الانترنت
وبالتالي
هو فعليا يحاول ان يكسب قليلا من هذه
المساحه ومن خلال ضم واستخدام ودمج تقنيات
الذكاء الاصطناعي التي تحاول ان تلخص
نتائج البحث بشكل اكثر فائده للباحثين فهي
فعليا سوف تاخذ وقت طويل لا يستطيع ان
نقول انه ممكن انه مباشره هذا صعب طيب
دكتور الى جانب الحديث عن المنافسه اليوم
صار في رسائل واجابات صادمه تصدر من بنك
يرسل الى مجموعه من المستخدمين رسائل
غريبه عجيبه يعني هذه الرسائل فيها
الكلمات الفاظ بذيئه وكمان كانه يعاني من
اضطراب عاطفي هل نحن اوصلنا هذا الروبوت
لهذا المستوى هو طبعا
هذه هذا هذا الجهاز او هذه الخوارزميه هي
طبعا تتعلم مما تغذى من المعلومات او
البيانات وبالتالي اذا تم طبعا تغذيه هذه
التقنيات ببيانات فيها نوع من التحيز
وفيها نوع من عدم الاكتمال وايضا لربما
خطابات او جالس او هي يعني دردشات فيها
هذا النوع من العواطف التي تظهر بشكل سلبي
فهو طبعا سوف يؤثر على اليه طبعا بناء
الحوار وبناء هذه طبعا الكلمات وبالتالي
تقنيه ما زالت هي ليست ناضجه مئه بالمئه
وتحتاج ايضا الى مزيد من التحكم في اليه
بناء الاجابات التلقائيه
وهي ايضا ليست لا تقف فقط عند حد الكلمات
الغير لائقه بل ايضا الى فبركه وهل وست
حقائق علميه وهذا طبعا ما يثير الخوف بانه
يعني
تنكر نحن الان في عام 2023 وهي تحاول ان
تقنع بعض المستخدمين انه احنا ما زلنا في
2022 الى ايضا الكثير من المشاكل وبالتالي
التقنيه ما زالت تتطور وما زالت تحتاج
الكثير من القيود والضوابط التي تحدد
كيفيه انشاء هذا النص بحيث ان يكون نص
مفيد ونص ايضا خالي من اي جوانب سلبيه
طيب كمان استاذ انس اذا احنا رجعنا 2016
مايكروسوفت كانت اصدرت ايضا روبوت دردشه
وهذا الروبوت كان اسمه تايه وايضا يعمل
على اجابات وخلال 24 ساعه تم ايقافه هل
يمكن ان نسمع يوما ما مثلا عن ايقاف العمل
بينك
بينك هو مجال يعني برنامج يستخدمه في
التصفح ولكن الضبط ما تم عمله فعليا حاليا
وضع ضوابط بحيث انه في الجلسه الواحده لا
نستطيع ان نسال اكثر من 50 من خمسه اسئله
في اليوم الواحد طبعا 50 سؤال هذا النوع
من اذا طبعا اذا اصبحنا في عمليه سجال بين
الروبوت وبين الانسان من نوعين من ناحيه
الاسئله سوف يؤدي الى تكوين اجابات غير
صحيحه وغير مفيده وبالتالي ما عملته
مايكروسوفت هي حددت انه في الجلسه الواحده
خمس اسئله لانه تقريبا 90% من الناس
يحصلوا على اجابات مفيده بعد ذلك سوف يصبح
الروبوت يقوم بانشاء معلومات مكرره وغير
مفيده او توجه لان تستفزه وان يقول اشياء
غير مريحه او غير مناسبه ويتهم اليوم
بالعنصريه لانه يعيد صياغه ما يقوله البشر
اي حاكم البشر شكرا انا سنجداوي اكاديمي
ومستشار في اداره العمل الرقميه نورتنا
شكرا لك شكرا